[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je suis venu vous parler donc du
rêve et de l'audace il nous plaît
d'ailleurs que nos enfants aient des
rêves et comme parents nous voulons leur
donner tous les moyens pour qu'il puisse
un jour les réaliser attention je
précise leur rêve pas les nôtres
n'allons pas reporter fut rude ou
propres névroses dans leur demandant d'y
répondre mais qu'est ce que ça signifie
rêver car enfin c'est pas le propre de
l'homme les animaux restent aussi et
peut-être plus que nous parfois prenons
l'opossum ou le tattoo géants qui sont
les plus gros dormeurs ils peuvent rêver
jusqu'à 6 heures alors que nous en
moyenne nous rêvons deux heures par nuit
on peut se demander aussi à quoi ils
rêvent un chat par exemple peut-être de
la souris qui n'a pas réussi à attraper
aujourd'hui et qu'il attrape
enfin dans son rêve mais justement c'est
peut-être ça qui distingue l'homme c'est
que nous ne serons jamais rien du rêve
des animaux auxquels manquent la parole
tandis que l'homme peut raconter ses
rêves et pas seulement sur un divan il
peut les communiquer au dehors
et bien plus encore il peut avoir la
volonté et l'audace de les réaliser pour
de bon alors vous comprenez tout
pourrait se renverser par rapport à la
manière dont nous a parlé freud est ce
qui nous a pris sur les rêves
le rêve les rêves ne serait pas chargée
uniquement de satisfaire nos désirs
frustrés ils auraient ce privilège
étonnant de faire naître en nous des
désirs auxquelles nous n'aurions pas
même penser que nous n'aurions pas même
imaginer sans enjeu et qui permettrait
quelques-uns de vouloir les satisfaire
dans la réalité
quitte à transformer le monde pour qu'il
en soit ainsi traverser l'atlantique à
la rame battre un record
c'est à dire
r ce que jusqu'ici aucun homme n'avait
réussi à faire penser un monde sans
monnaie sans argent ne rêvons pas non
plus sans monnaies et est vrai pour cela
réinventer le métier de paysan après
qu'on vous a répété mille fois qu'en
france il était devenu difficile voire
impossible d'en vivre
c'est ça qui est étonnant c'est que
l'homme n'a pas seulement des besoins
fixé d'avancé par son génome
comme on peut le supposer de la bei qui
n'aspire qu'à se nourrir du nectar des
fleurs
il désire il n'a rien et il désire tout
ils désirent des choses dont il n'est
pas capable et c'est cela qui est
étonnant et peut-être que le rêve pour
autant qu'on ne confonde pas avec le
besoin n'est que cela désir de
l'impossible tel serait alors la
puissance du rêve que de nous permettre
d'anticiper sur sa réalisation de nous
faire croire follement que l'impossible
est possible et de permettre à quelques
uns d'avoir l'audace de le tenter
vous comprenez pourquoi il faudra penser
ensemble le rêve et l'audace car ce
serait la plus grande vertu du rêve que
de susciter des audacieux sans quoi le
rêve n'est qu'un songe
il n'aura été que mensonge c'est cela
qui doit nous inviter en quelque sorte à
nous intéresser aussi à l'audace alors
on me présente comme philosophe c'est
trop d'honneur
évidemment mais en même temps les
philosophes passe souvent pour être des
doux rêveurs du temps même de socrate le
poète comique aristophane dans la pièce
les nuées se moquer
dans son pan soir le philosophe est un
peu perdu un peu fou la tête dans les
nuages mais peut-être que je suis aussi
un peu en tout cas assez pour me
reprocher parfois ma distraction mais je
suis aussi ici présent en tant que
membre de la revue esprit laquelle revue
s'est donné pour tâche de comprendre le
monde qui vient et pour autant justement
elle m'invite de plus en plus à
descendre dans la cité à rejoindre le
monde et non à mon évadés et affirmer
qu'à la pensée il faut toujours joindre
la volonté la persévérance l'action en
un mot l'audace car nous disions donc
qu'il y avait deux manières de rêver
l'une qu'il faut encourager qui incite à
transformer le rêve en réalité et
l'autre qu'il faut craindre qu' au
contraire nous invite plutôt à prendre
vos rêves pour des réalités
et ce qui me frappe c'est qu'aujourd'hui
c'est cette deuxième sorte de rêve qui
domine car je lis de le dire l'homme est
paresseux c'est à dire qu'il va toujours
au plus court il choisit toujours le
chemin le plus court et le rêve d'une
certaine manière c'est une façon de
satisfaire à bon marché
or les nouvelles technologies avec ses
moyens très puissant de communication
comme l'internet
eh bien nous ont rendu un peu paresseux
elles nous ont plongés dans un monde
virtuel où nos vies numériques ressemble
de plus en plus un rêve éveillé en tout
cas où rêve et réalité tendent à se
confondre expliquant qu est ce que le
réel c'est ce qui nous résistent et
qu'est ce que le rêve c'est quand plus
rien ne lui résiste quand l'objet est
obtenue par le désir aussitôt qu'il est
imaginé immédiatement parce que le réel
n'est pas là pour s'opposer qui nous
obligerait à vouloir et à créer les
moyens pour l'atteindre
c'est d'ailleurs ainsi que jackson
définissait le
le rêve c'est la réalité - la volonté
or à force de voir les réalités à
travers vos écrans eh bien nous avons
fini par oublier nos écrans et aussi
qu'ils font écran et nous coupent
quelque peu du réel en sorte que nous
sommes de plus en plus relié à
l'internet est de moins en moins à notre
entourage et les images qui nous
parviennent et bien ressemblent plus à
des images oniriques cas des images
proprement perçu car qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire percevoir percevoir dans la
réalité toujours c'est en même temps une
invitation à agir quand je vois devant
moi un verre d'eau
j'ai la possibilité de le saisir de le
porter à la bouche
bref d'agir et étancher ma soif
or avec l'écran numérique
l'image est séparé de son prolongement
moteur c'est à dire que elle inhibe
l'action au lieu de la provoquer et donc
modifier nos comportements
et d'ailleurs nous avons de plus en plus
pris l'habitude et bien de regarder sans
agir ou en tout cas en agissant le moins
possible comme par exemple faire ses
courses sur internet d'un simple clic on
pressent d'ailleurs que vos actions
s'accompliront de plus en plus à travers
l'internet
nous sommes devenus essentiellement
comme le dit deleuze des voyants c'est à
dire que par tous nos moyens télé car tv
en grec ça veut dire à distance et bien
nous survolons le monde entier et nous
voyons d'autant plus loin que nous ne
pouvons pas réagir
on se souvient de cet homme politique
français accusés de fraude fiscale pour
ne pas avoir payé ses impôts et qui pour
sa défense s'expliquer expliqué
il souffrait de phobies administrative
j'avoue avoir ri avoir souri à l'époque
comme tout le monde mais à la réflexion
peut-être que c'était vrai je veux dire
que de nouvelles pathologies petite
grande vont bientôt n'être de nos vies
numériques
je vous conseille à cet égard le livre
récent de maele renoir qui écrit sur sa
propre expérience de l'internet
le livre s'intitule fragments d'une
mémoire infinie
le livre se dévore et l'auteur y évoque
entre autres le cas d'un homme qui a
trop naviguer sur le web et pour qui
certains gestes physiques sont devenus
étrange presque impossible complètement
désemparé lorsqu'il s'agit de remplir un
formulaire et de l'envoyer par la poste
mais tel serait justement la situation
nouvelle que la vie numérique nous a
fait qui fait que nous avons plus de mal
à croire aux événements qui nous arrive
je veux dire à croire vraiment à leur
réalité et c'est justement ce qui nous
porte aussi à admirer ce qui encore
l'audace de créer qui ont encore
l'audace d'inventer qui savent que les
objets techniques ne sont que de simples
outils et non pas des objets magiques
alors que faut-il attendre de la
philosophie car je n'ai pas du tout
voulu dire que nous n'agissions pas au
contraire jamais nous n'avons été aussi
mobile agitée dans l'accélération du
monde
simplement nous ne savons pas toujours
très bien ce que nous faisons
la tête dans le guidon avec la vitesse
acquise nous réagissons beaucoup plus
que nous agissons par action par
impulsion autrement dit le problème
vient plutôt qu'il s'agit de penser
ensemble le rêve et l'action dans un
juste équilibre et que là le problème
c'est que nous n'agissons et ne rêvons
si je puis dire que par alternance de
façon alternée et non pas ensemble
alors que faut-il entendre par
philosophie je vais peut-être ne pas me
faire d'amis seulement et je vous prie
de m'en excuser
mais il ne faut pas attendre de la
philosophie qu'elle vous promettre
justement de transformer vos rêves en
réalité comme le font d'innombrables
livres consacrés au développement
personnel et qui se vendent à des
milliers d'exemplaires des types l'homme
qui voulait être heureux ou cesser
d'être gentil soyez vrai c'est pour moi
un marché de dupes qui fleur qui fleurit
au fond sur le terreau de nos misères
parce qu'à vrai dire ces livres sont le
contraire de ce qu'ils promettent ils
endorment il alterne encore rêve et
actions sans les articuler par exemple
quand on vous donne nous permet de
surmonter vos anxiétés d'avoir les
moyens de vaincre vos anxiétés ou
d'améliorer vos performances
au fond il s'agit - là de vous épanouir
que de mieux épouser le monde tel qu'il
va
sans le transformer ce serait en quelque
sorte comme le yoga comme
le bouddhisme à l'occidentale peut-être
aussi comme les antidépresseurs la
manière pour l'individu moderne de
continuer sa vie frénétique sans en
changer
sorte de complément indispensable
idéologique de la dynamique libéral de
nos sociétés modernes
ce serait au fond comment allait bien
dans un monde qui va mal
et bien c'est justement cela qu'on ne
doit pas attendre de la philosophie
enfin de crédit rien les philosophes se
reconnaissent à ce qu'ils se vendent
très peu à part peut-être monsieur
onfray pour parodier la chanson de
renaud
alors que doit être la philosophie vers
quoi doit-elle tendre et bien justement
elle doit peut-être porter son regard
vers ces personnalités remarquables qui
ont eu l'énergie de transformer le rêve
en réalité c'est un entrepreneur ses
éducateurs paysans artisans artistes
ingénieurs tous en quelque sorte qu'ils
ont su non pas alterner rêve et réalité
mais qui ont su faire passer
continuellement le rêve dans la réalité
dans l'action avec l'énergie de l'audace
et c'est cet effort auquel aspire la
revue esprit en réunissant historiens
philosophes sociologues juristes et tant
d'autres c'est à dire penser à égale
distance d'un côté de l'esprit
désincarné et de l'autre de la réaction
compulsive et c'est ce que doit être
aussi justement la philosophie en tout
cas c'est l'effort qu'elle va fournir
elles ne doivent surtout pas promettre
le bonheur ici et maintenant elle n'a
pas davantage proclamé l'oeil sec que le
bateau coule
à part peut-être monsieur onfray si le
veut elle doit d'abord se persuader
comme je le suis qu'on ne peut aller
bien qu'en faisant en sorte que le monde
aille mieux
et permettez moi de
conclure ainsi la philosophie ne peut
penser vrai ne peut penser juste que si
elle garde près du coeur en même temps
le mot de danton qu'il prononça un jour
décisif devant l'assemblée législative
messieurs et permettez moi d'ajouter
mesdames il faut de l'audace encore de
l'audace toujours de l'audace
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]